okay fermium it has absolutely no use as
far as anyone knows except that it's
extremely radioactive as named after
Enrico Fermi who's a well-known
physicist firmly was an Italian
physicist who in the 1930s was the first
person to discover artificial
radioactivity this is where neutrons
which had only recently been discovered
when he did these experiments hit and
then element that is not radioactive
increased the weight of the nucleus but
not the number of protons and caused it
to fall apart and by radioactive decay
and it also like einsteinium where was
first found in the debris serve a
nuclear bomb in fact the very first
nuclear bomb that was ever tested
shortly after the fascists took power in
Italy Fermi moved to the United States
and as part of the Manhattan Project for
building the atomic bomb he built the
first nuclear reactor under the football
stadium in the squash court and the
football stadium at Chicago University
of Chicago right in the center of
Chicago and they filled the squash court
with blocks of carbon with holes in the
middle through which they put rods of
uranium so the first ever sustained
nuclear reaction took place in the
sports field of University of Chicago
and if you go now there the stadium
itself has been completely demolished
but there's a rather fine monument for
the birth of the atomic era